PROFESSOR: Well today we're
going to learn about something
quite amazing.
We're going to understand what
we mean by a program a little
bit more profoundly than
we have up till now.
Up till now, we've been thinking
of programs as
describing machines.
So for example, looking at this
still store, we see here
is a program for factorial.
And what it is, is a character
string description, if you
will, of the wiring
diagram of a
potentially infinite machine.
And we can look at that
a little bit and
just see the idea.
That this is a sort of compact
notation which says, if n is
0, the result is one.
Well here comes n coming into
this machine, and if it's 0,
then I control this switch in
such a way that the switch
allows the output to be one.
Otherwise, it's n times
factorial of n minus one.
Well, I'm computing factorial of
n minus one and multiplying
that by n, and, in the case that
it's not 0, this switch
makes the output come
from there.
Of course, this is a machine
with a potentially infinite
number of parts, because
factorial occurs within
factorial, so we don't know
how deep it has to be.
But that's basically what our
notation for programs really
means to us at this point.
It's a character string
description, if you will, of a
wiring diagram that could also
be drawn some other way.
And, in fact, many people have
proposed to me, programming
languages look graphical
like this.
I'm not sure I believe there
are many advantages.
The major disadvantage, of
course, is that it takes up
more space on a page, and,
therefore, it's harder to pack
into a listing or to
edit very well.
But in any case, there's
something very remarkable that
can happen in the competition
world which is that you can
have something called
a universal machine.
If we look at the second
slide, what we see is a
special machine called eval.
There is a machine called eval,
and I'm going to show it
to you today.
It's very simple.
What is remarkable is that it
will fit on the blackboard.
However, eval is a machine
which takes as input a
description of another
machine.
It could take the wiring
diagram of a
factorial machine as input.
Having done so, it becomes a
simulator for the factorial
machine such that, if you put
a six in, out comes a 720.
That's a very remarkable
sort of machine.
And the most amazing part of
it is that it fits on a
blackboard.
By contrast, one could imagine
in the analog electronics
world a very different machine,
a machine which also
was, in some sense, universal,
where you gave a circuit
diagram as one of the inputs,
for example, of this little
low-pass filter, one-pole
low-pass filter.
And you can imagine that
you could, for
example, scan this out--
the scan lines are the signal
that's describing what this
machine is to simulate--
then the analog of that which
is made out of electrical
circuits, should configure
itself into a filter that has
the frequency response
specified
by the circuit diagram.
That's a very hard machine to
make, and, surely, there's no
chance that I could put
it on a blackboard.
So we're going to see an
amazing thing today.
We're going to see,
on the blackboard,
the universal machine.
And we'll see that among other
things, it's extremely simple.
Now, we're getting very close
to the real spirit in the
computer at this point.
So I have to show a certain
amount of reverence and
respect, so I'm going to wear
a suit jacket for the only
time that you'll ever see me
wear a suit jacket here.
And I think I'm also going to
put on an appropriate hat for
the occasion.
Now, this is a lecturer which
I have to warn you--
let's see, normally, people
under 40 and who don't have
several children are advised
to be careful.
If they're really worried, they
should leave. Because
there's a certain amount of
mysticism that will appear
here which may be disturbing
and cause
trouble in your minds.
Well in any case, let's see,
I wish to write for you the
evaluator for Lisp.
Now the evaluator isn't
very complicated.
It's very much like all the
programs we've seen already.
That's the amazing part of it.
It's going to be-- and I'm going
to write it right here--
it's a program called eval.
And it's a procedure of two
arguments in expression of an
environment.
And like every interesting
procedure, it's a case analysis.
But before I start on this, I
want to tell you some things.
The program we're going to write
on the blackboard is
ugly, dirty, disgusting, not the
way I would write this is
a professional.
It is written with concrete
syntax, meaning you've got
really to use lots of CARs and
CDRs which is exactly what I
told you not to do.
That's on purpose in this case,
because I want it to be
small, compact, fit on the
blackboard so you can get the
whole thing.
So I don't want to use long
names like I normally use.
I want to use CAR-CDR
because it's short.
Now, that's a trade-off.
I don't want you writing
programs like this.
This is purely for an effect.
Now, you're going to have to
work a little harder to read
it, but I'm going to try
to make it clear
as I'm writing it.
I'm also--
this is a pretty much complete
interpreter, but there's going
to be room for putting
in more things--
I'm going to leave out
definition and assignment,
just because they are not
essential, for a mathematical
reason I'll show you later and
also they take up more space.
But, in any case, what
do we have to do?
We have to do a dispatch which
breaks the types of
expressions up into particular
classes.
So that's what we're
going to have here.
Well, what expressions
are there?
Let's look at the kinds
of expressions.
We can have things like
the numeral three.
What do I want that to do?
I can make choices, but I think
right now, I want it to
be a three.
That's what I want.
So that's easy enough.
That means I want, if the
thing is a number, the
expression, that I want
the expression
itself as the answer.
Now the next possibility
is things that we
represent as symbols.
Examples of symbols are things
like x, n, eval, number, x.
What do I mean them to be?
Those are things that stand
for other things.
Those are the variables
of our language.
And so I want to be able to say,
for example, that x, for
example, transforms to it's
value which might be three.
Or I might ask something
like car.
I want to have as its value--
be something like some
procedure, which I don't know
what is inside there, perhaps
a machine language code or
something like that.
So, well, that's easy enough.
I'm going to push that
off on someone else.
If something is a symbol, if
the expression is a symbol,
then I want the answer to be
the result, looking up the
expression in the environment.
Now the environment is a
dictionary which maps the
symbol names to their values.
And that's all it is.
How it's done?
Well, we'll see that later.
It's very easy.
It's easy to make data
structures that are tables of
various sorts.
But it's only a table, and this
is the access routine for
some table.
Well, the next thing, another
kind of expression--
you have things that are
described constants that are
not numbers, like 'foo.
Well, for my convenience,
I want to syntactically
transform that into a list
structure which is, quote foo.
A quoted object, whatever it is,
is going to be actually an
abbreviation, which is not
part of the evaluator but
happens somewhere else, an
abbreviation for an expression
that looks like this.
This way, I can test for the
type of the expression as
being a quotation by examining
the car of the expression.
So I'm not going to worry about
that in the evaluator.
It's happening somewhere
earlier in
the reader or something.
If the expression of the
expression is quote, then what
I want, I want quote foo to
itself evaluate to foo.
It's a constant.
This is just a way of saying
that this evaluates to itself.
What is that?
That's the second of the list.
It's the second element of the
list. The second element of the
list is it's CADR. So I'm
just going to write
here, CADR.
What else do we have here?
We have lambda expressions,
for example,
lambda of x plus x y.
Well, I going have to have some
representation for the
procedure which is the value of
an expression, of a lambda
expression.
The procedure here is not
the expression lambda x.
That's the description of it,
the textual description.
However, what what I going
to expect to see here is
something which contains an
environment as one of its
parts if I'm implementing
a lexical language.
And so what I'd like to see
is some type flags.
I'm going to have to be able
to distinguish procedures
later, procedures which were
produced by lambdas, from ones
that may be primitive.
And so I'm going to have some
flag, which I'll just
arbitrarily call closure, just
for historical reasons.
Now, to say what parts of
this are important.
I'm going to need to know
the bound variable
list and the body.
Well, that's the CDR of this, so
it's going to be x and plus
x y and some environment.
Now this is not something that
users should ever see, this is
purely a representation,
internally,
for a procedure object.
It contains a bound variable
list, a body, and an
environment, and some type tag
saying, I am a procedure.
I'm going to make one now.
So if the CAR of the expression
is quote lambda,
then what I'm going
to put here is--
I'm going to make a list of
closure, the CDR of the
procedure description was
everything except the lambda,
and the current environment.
This implements the rule
for environments in the
environment model.
It has to do with construction
of procedures from lambda
expressions.
The environment that was
around at the time the
evaluator encountered the
lambda expression is the
environment where the procedure
resulting interprets
it's free variables.
So that's part of that.
And so we have to capture that
environment as part of the
procedure object.
And we'll see how that
gets used later.
There are also conditional
expressions of things like
COND of say, p one, e
one, p two, e two.
Where this is a predicate, a
predicate is a thing that is
either true or false, and the
expression to be evaluated if
the predicate is true.
A set of clauses, if you
will, that's the
name for such a thing.
So I'm going put that
somewhere else.
We're going to worry about that
in another piece of code.
So EQ--
if the CAR of the expression is
COND, then I'm going to do
nothing more than evaluate
the COND, the CDR of the
expression.
That's all the clauses in the
environment that I'm given.
Well, there's one more case,
arbitrary thing like the sum
of x and three, where this
is an operator applied to
operands, and there's nothing
special about it.
It's not one of the special
cases, the special forms.
These are the special forms.
And if I were writing here a
professional program, again, I
would somehow make this
data directed.
So there wouldn't be a sequence
of conditionals here,
there'd be a dispatch on some
bits if I were trying to do
this in a more professional
way.
So that, in fact, I can add to
the thing without changing my
program much.
So, for example, they would run
fast, but I'm not worried
about that.
Here we're trying to look
at this in its entirety.
So it's else.
Well, what do we do?
In this case, I have to somehow
do an addition.
Well, I could find out
what the plus is.
I have to find out what the
x and the three are.
And then I have to apply the
result of finding what the
plus is to the result of
finding out what the x
and the three are.
We'll have a name for that.
So I'm going to apply the result
of evaluating the CAR
of the expression--
the car of the expression
is the operator--
in the environment given.
So evaluating the operator
gets me the procedure.
Now I have to evaluate all the
operands to get the arguments.
I'll call that EVLIST, the CDR
of the operands, of the
expression, with respect
to the environment.
EVLIST will come up later--
EVLIST, apply, COND pair,
COND, lambda, define.
So that what you are seeing here
now is pretty much all
there is in the evaluator
itself.
It's the case dispatch on the
type of the expression with
the default being a general
application or a combination.
Now there is lots of things
we haven't defined yet.
Let's just look at them
and see what they are.
We're going to have to do
this later, evcond.
We have to write apply.
We're going to have to
write EVLIST. We're
going to write LOOKUP.
I think that's everything,
isn't there?
Everything else is something
which is simple, or primitive,
or something like that.
And, of course, we could many
more special forms here, but
that would be a bad idea in
general in a language.
You make a language very
complicated by putting a lot
of things in there.
The number of reserve words
that should exist in a
language should be no more than
a person could remember
on his fingers and toes.
And I get very upset with
languages which have hundreds
of reserve words.
But that's where the
reserve words go.
Well, now let's get to
the next part of
this, the kernel, apply.
What else is this doing?
Well, apply's job is to take a
procedure and apply it to its
arguments after both have been
evaluated to come up with a
procedure and the arguments
rather the operator symbols
and the operand symbols,
whatever they are--
symbolic expressions.
So we will define apply to be a
procedure of two arguments,
a procedure and arguments.
And what does it do?
It does nothing very
complicated.
It's got two cases.
Either the procedure
is primitive--
And I don't know exactly
how that is done.
It's possible there's some type
information just like we
made closure for, here, being
the description of the type of
a compound thing--
probably so.
But it is not essential how that
works, and, in fact, it
turns out, as you probably know
or have deduced, that you
don't need any primitives
anyway.
You can compute anything without
them because some of
the lambda that I've
been playing with.
But it's nice to have them.
So here we're going to do
some magic which I'm
not going to explain.
Go to machine language,
apply primop.
Here's how it adds.
Execute an add instruction.
However, the interesting part
of a language is the glue by
which the predicates
are glued together.
So let's look at that.
Well, the other possibility is
that this is a compound made
up by executing a lambda
expression, this
is a compound procedure.
Well, we'll check its type.
If it is closure, if it's one of
those, then I have to do an
eval of the body.
The way I do this, the way I
deal with this at all, is the
way I evaluate the application
of a procedure to its
arguments, is by evaluating the
body of the procedure in
the environment resulting from
extending the environment of
the procedure with the bindings
of the formal
parameters of the procedure
to the arguments that
were passed to it.
That was a long sentence.
Well that's easy enough.
Now here's going to be
a lot of CAR-CDRing.
I have to get the body
of the procedure.
Where's the body of the
procedure in here?
Well here's the CAR, here's
the CDR is the
whole rest of this.
So here's the CADR. And so I
see, what I have here is the
body is the second element
of the second
element of the procedure.
So it's the CADR of the
CADR or the CADADR.
It's the C-A-D-A-D-R, CADADR
of the procedure.
To evaluate the body in the
result of binding that's
making up more environment,
well I need the formal
parameters of the of the
procedure, what is that?
That's the CAR of the CDR.
It's horrible isn't it?
--of the procedure.
Bind that to the arguments
that were passed in the
environment, which is passed
also as part of the procedure.
Well, that's the CAR of the
CDR of the CDR of this,
CADADR, of the procedure.
Bind, eval, pair, COND,
lamda, define--
Now, of course, if I were being
really a neat character,
and I was being very careful, I
would actually put an extra
case here for checking for
certain errors like, did you
try to apply one
to an argument?
You get a undefined
procedure type.
So I may as well
do that anyway.
--else, some sort of
error, like that.
Now, of course, again, in some
sort of more real system,
written for professional
reasons, this would be written
with a case analysis done by
some sort of dispatch.
Over here, I would probably have
other cases like, is this
compiled code?
It's very important.
I might have distinguished the
kind of code that's produced
by a directly evaluating a
lambda in interpretation from
code that was produced by
somebody's compiler or
something like that.
And we'll talk about
that later.
Or is this a piece Fortran
program I have
to go off and execute.
It's a perfectly possible
thing, at this
point, to do that.
In fact, in this concrete syntax
evaluator I'm writing
here, there's an assumption
built in that this is Lisp,
because I'm using
CARs and CDRs.
CAR means the operator, and
CDR means the operand.
In the text, there is an
abstract syntax evaluator for
which these could be--
these are given abstract names
like operator, and operand,
and all these other things
are like that.
And, in that case, you could
reprogram it to be ALGOL with
no problem.
Well, here we have added another
couple of things that
we haven't defined.
I don't think I'll worry about
these at all, however, this
one will be interesting later.
Let's just proceed through
this and get it done.
There's only two more
blackboards so it
can't be very long.
It's carefully tailored
to exactly fit.
Well, what do we have left?
We have to define EVLIST,
which is over here.
And EVLIST is nothing more than
a map down a bunch of
operands producing arguments.
But I'm going to write it out.
And one of the reasons I'm going
to write this out is for
a mystical reason, which is I
want to make this evaluator so
simple that it can understand
itself.
I'm going to really worry
about that a little bit.
So let's write it
out completely.
See, I don't want to worry about
whether or not the thing
can pass functional arguments.
The value evaluator is not
going to use them.
The evaluator is not going to
produce functional values.
So even if there were a
different, alternative
language that were very close
to this, this evaluates a
complex language like Scheme
which does allow procedural
arguments, procedural values,
and procedural data.
But even if I were evaluating
ALGOL, which doesn't allow
procedural values, I could
use this evaluator.
And this evaluator
is not making any
assumptions about that.
And, in fact, if this value were
to be restricted to not
being able to that, it wouldn't
matter, because it
doesn't use any of those
clever things.
So that's why I'm arranging
this to be super simple.
This is sort of the kernel
of all possible language
evaluators.
How about that?
Evlist--
well, what is it?
It's the procedure of two
arguments, l and an
environment, where l is a list
such that if the list of
arguments is the empty list,
then the result is the empty
list. Otherwise, I want to
cons up the result of
evaluating the CAR of the
list of operands in the
environment.
So I want the first operand
evaluated, and I'm going to
make a list of the results by
CONSing that onto the result
of this EVLISTing as a CDR
recursion, the CDR of the list
relative to the same
environment.
Evlist, cons, else, COND,
lambda, define--
And I have one more that I want
to put on the blackboard.
It's the essence of
this whole thing.
And there's some sort
of next layer down.
Conditionals--
conditionals are the only thing
left that are sort of
substantial.
Then below that, we have to
worry about things like lookup
and bind, and we'll look
at that in a second.
But of the substantial stuff at
this level of detail, next
important thing is how you
deal with conditionals.
Well, how do we have a
conditional thing?
It's a procedure of a set of
clauses and an environment.
And what does it do?
It says, if I've no more
clauses, well, I have to give
this a value.
It could be that it
was an error.
Supposing it run off
the end of a
conditional, it's pretty arbitrary.
It's up to me as programmer to
choose what I want to happen.
It's convenient for me, right
now, to write down that this
has a value which is the empty
list, doesn't matter.
For error checking,
some people might
prefer something else.
But the interesting things
are the following ones.
If I've got an else clause--
You see, if I have a list of
clauses, then each clause is a
list. And so the predicate
part is
the CAAR of the clauses.
It's the CAR, which is the first
part of the first clause
in the list of clauses.
If it's an else, then it means
I want my result of the
conditional to be the result
of evaluating the matching
expression.
So I eval the CADR. So this is
the first clause, the second
element of it, CADAR--
CADAR of a CAR--
of the clauses, with respect
to the environment.
Now the next possibility
is more interesting.
If it's false, if the first
predicate in the predicate
list is not an else, and it's
not false, if it's not the
word else, and if it's
not a false thing--
Let's write down what it is
if it's a false thing.
If the result of evaluating
the first
predicate, the clauses--
respect the environment, if that
evaluation yields false,
then it means, I want to look
at the next clause.
So I want to discard
the first one.
So we just go around loop,
evcond, the CDR of the clauses
relative to that environment.
And otherwise, I had a true
clause, in which case, what I
want is to evaluate the CADAR
of the clauses relative to
that environment.
Boy, it's almost done.
It's quite close to done.
I think we're going to
finish this part off.
So just buzzing through this
evaluator, but so far you're
seeing almost everything.
Let's look at the next
transparency here.
Here is bind.
Bind is for making more table.
And what we are going to
do here is make a--
we're going to make a no-frame
for an environment structure.
The environment structure is
going to be represented as a
list of frames.
So given an existing environment
structure, I'm
going to make a new environment
structure by
consing a new frame onto the
existing environment
structure, where the new frame
consists of the result of
pairing up the variables, which
are the bound variables
of the procedure I'm applying,
to the values which are the
arguments that were passed
that procedure.
This is just making a list,
adding a new element to our
list of frames, which is an
environment structure, to make
a new environment.
Where pair-up is very simple.
Pair-up is nothing more than if
I have a list of variables
and a list of values, well, if
I run out of variables and if
I run out of values,
everything's OK.
Otherwise, I've given
too many arguments.
If I've not run out of
variables, but I've run out of
values, that I have
too few arguments.
And in the general case, where
I don't have any errors, and
I'm not done, then I really am
just adding a new pair of the
first variable with the first
argument, the first value,
onto a list resulting from
pairing-up the rest of the
variables with the rest
of the values.
Lookup is of course
equally simple.
If I have to look up a symbol
in an environment, well, if
the environment is empty, then
I've got an unbound variable.
Otherwise, what I'm going to do
is use a special pair list
lookup procedure, which we'll
have very shortly, of the
symbol in the first frame
of the environment.
Since I know the environment is
not empty, it must have a
first frame.
So I lookup the symbol
in the first frame.
That becomes the value
cell here.
And then, if the value cell is
empty, if there is no such
value cell, then I have to
continue and look at the rest
of the frames.
It means there was nothing
found there.
So that's a property of ASSQ is
it returns emptiness if it
doesn't find something.
but if it did find something,
then I'm going to use the CDR
of the value cell here, which is
the thing that was the pair
consisting of the variable
and the value.
So the CDR of it is
the value part.
Finally, ASSQ is something
you've probably seen already.
ASSQ takes a symbol and a list
of pairs, and if the list is
empty, it's empty.
If the symbol is the first
thing in the list--
That's an error.
That should be CAAR, C-A-A-R.
Everybody note that.
Right there, OK?
And in any case, if the symbol
is the CAAR of the A list,
then I want the first, the first
pair, in the A list. So,
in other words, if this is the
key matching the right entry,
otherwise, I want to look up
that symbol in the rest. Sorry
for producing a bug,
bugs appear.
Well, in any case, you're
pretty much seeing
the whole thing now.
It's a very beautiful thing,
even though it's written in an
ugly style, being the kernel
of every language.
I suggest that we just--
let's look at it for a while.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Are there any questions?
Alright, I suppose it's time
to take a small break then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, now we're just going to do
a little bit of practice
understanding what it is
we've just shown you.
What we're going to do is go
through, in detail, an
evaluation by informally
substituting through the
interpreter.
And since we have no assignments
or definitions in
this interpreter, we have no
possible side effects, and so
the we can do substitution with
impunity and not worry
about results.
So the particular problem I'd
like to look at is it an
interesting one.
It's the evaluation of quote,
open, open, open, lambda of x,
lambda of y plus x y, lambda,
lambda, applied to three,
applied to four, in some
global environment
which I'll call e0.
So what we have here is a
procedure of one argument x,
which produces as its value a
procedure of one argument y,
which adds x to y.
We are applying the procedure
of one argument x to three.
So x should become three.
And the result of that should
be procedure of one argument
y, which will then apply to 4.
And there is a very simple
case, they will
then add those results.
And now in order to do that, I
want to make a very simple
environment model.
And at this point, you should
already have in your mind the
environments that
this produces.
But we're going to start out
with a global environment,
which I'll call e0,
which is that.
And it's going to have in it
things, definitions for plus,
and times, and--
using Greek letters, isn't that
interesting, for the objects--
and minus, and quotient, and
CAR, and CDR, and CONS, and
EQ, and everything else you
might imagine in a global
environment.
It's got something there for
each of those things,
something the machine is
born with, that's e0.
Now what does it mean to
do this evaluation?
Well, we go through the set of
special forms. First of all,
this is not a number.
This is not a symbol.
Gee, it's not a quoted
expression.
This is a quoted expression,
but that's not what I
interested in.
The question is, whether or not
the thing which is quoted
is quoted expression?
I'm evaluating an expression.
This just says it's this
particular expression.
This is not a quoted
expression.
It's not a thing that
begins with lambda.
begins with COND.
Therefore, it's an application
of its
of an operated operands.
It's a combination.
The combination thus has this
as the operator and this is
the operands.
Well, that means that what I'm
going to do is transform this
into apply of eval, of quote,
open, open lambda of
x, lambda of y--
I'm evaluating the operator--
plus x y, in the environment,
also e0, with the operands
that I'm going to apply this
to, the arguments being the
result of EVLIST, the list
containing four, fin e0.
I'm using this funny notation
here for e0 because this
should be that environment.
I haven't a name for it, because
I have no environment
to name it in.
So this is just a representation
of what would
be a quoted expression,
if you will.
The data structure, which is the
environment, goes there.
Well, that's what we're
seeing here.
Well in order to do this,
I have to do this, and
I have to do that.
Well this one's easy, so why
don't we do that one first.
This turns into apply
of eval-- just
copying something now.
Most of the substitution
rule is copying.
So I'm going to not say the
words when I copy, because
it's faster.
And then the EVLIST is going to
turn into a cons, of eval,
of four, in e0--
because it was not
an empty list--
onto the result of EVLISTing,
on the empty list, in e0.
And I'm going to start leaving
out steps soon, because it's
going to get boring.
But this is basically the same
thing as apply, of eval--
I'm going to keep doing this--
the lambda of x, the lambda of
y, plus xy, 3, close, e0.
I'm a pretty good machine.
Well, eval of four,
that's meets the
question, is it a number.
So that's cons, cons of 4.
And EVLIST of the empty
list is the empty
list, so that's this.
And that's very simple to
understand, because that means
the list containing
four itself.
So this is nothing more than
apply of eval, quote, open,
open, lambda of x, lambda of y,
plus x y, three applied to,
e0, applied to the list four--
bang.
So that's that step.
Now let's look at the next,
more interesting thing.
What do I do to evaluate that?
Evaluating this means
I have to evaluate--
Well, it's not.
It's nothing but
an application.
It's not one of the
special things.
If the application of this
operator, which we see here--
here's the operator--
applied to this operands,
that combination.
But we know how to do that,
because that's the last case
of the conditional.
So substituting in for this
evaluation, it's apply of eval
of the operator in the EVLIST
of the operands.
Well, it's apply, of apply, of
eval, of quote, open, lambda
of x, lambda of y, plus
x y, lambda, lambda,
in environment e0.
I'm going to short circuit the
evaluation of the operands ,
because they're the same
as they were before.
I got a list containing
three, apply that, and
apply that to four.
Well let's see.
Eval of a lambda expression
produces a procedure object.
So this is apply, of apply, of
the procedure object closure,
which contains the body of the
procedure, x, which is
lambda-- which binds
x [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the internals of the body, it
returns the procedure of one
argument y, which adds x to y.
Environment e0 is now captured
in it, because this was
evaluated with respect to e0.
e0 is part now of the
closure object.
Apply that to open, three,
close, apply, to open, 4,
close, apply.
So going from this step to this
step meant that I made up
a procedure object which
captured in it e0 as part of
the procedure object.
Now, we're going to pass
those to apply.
We have to apply this procedure
to that set of arguments.
Well, but that procedure
is not primitive.
It's, in fact, a thing which has
got the tag closure, and,
therefore, what we have
to do is do a bind.
We have to bind.
A new environment is made at
this point, which has as its
parent environment the one
over here, e0, that
environment.
And we'll call this one, e1.
Now what's bound in there?
x is bound to three.
So I have x equal three.
That's what's in there.
And we'll call that e1.
So what this transforms into
is an eval of the body of
this, which is this, the body
of that procedure, in the
environment that you just saw.
So that's an apply, of eval,
quote, open, lambda of y, plus
x y-- the body--
in e1.
And apply the result of that
to four, open, close, 4--
list of arguments.
Well, that's sensible enough
because evaluating a lambda, I
know what to do.
That means I apply, the
procedure which is closure,
binds one argument y, adds x to
y, with e1 captured in it.
And you should really
see this.
I somehow manufactured
a closure.
I should've put this here.
There was one over here too.
Well, there's one here now.
I've captured e1, and this is
the procedure of one argument
y, whatever this is.
That's what that is there,
that closure.
I'm going to apply
that to four.
Well, that's easy enough.
That means I have to make a
new environment by copying
this pointer, which was the
pointer of the procedure,
which binds y equal 4 with
that environment.
And here's my new environment,
which I'll call e2.
And, of course, this application
then is evaluate
the body in e2.
So this is eval, the body,
which is plus x y, in the
environment e2.
But this is an application, so
this is the apply, of eval,
plus in e2, an EVLIST, quote,
open, x y, in e2.
Well, but let's see.
That is apply, the
object which is a
result of that and plus.
So here we are in e2, plus is
not here, it's not here, oh,
yes, but's here as some
primitive operator.
So it's the primitive operator
for addition.
Apply that to the result of
evaluating x and y in e2.
But we can see that x is
three and y is four.
So that's a three
and four, here.
And that magically produces
for me a seven.
I wanted to go through this so
you would see, essentially,
one important ingredient, which
is what's being passed
around, and who owns what,
and what his job is.
So what do we have here?
We have eval, and we have apply,
the two main players.
And there is a big loop the
goes around like this.
Which is eval produces
a procedure and
arguments for apply.
Now some things eval
could do by itself.
Those are little self
things here.
They're not interesting.
Also eval evaluates all of the
arguments, one after another.
That's not very interesting.
Apply can apply some procedures
like plus, not very
interesting.
However, if apply can't apply
a procedure like plus, it
produces an expression and
environment for eval.
The procedural arguments wrap up
essentially the state of a
computation and, certainly, the
expression of environment.
And so what we're actually going
to do next is not the
complete state, because
it doesn't say
who wants the answers.
But what we're going to do--
it's always got something like
an expression of environment or
procedure and arguments as
the main loop that we're
going around.
There are minor little sub
loops like eval through
EVLIST, or eval through evcond,
or apply through a
primitive apply.
But they're not the
essential things.
So that's what I wanted
you to see.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to
understand how x got down to
three instead of four.
At the early part of the--
PROFESSOR: Here.
You want to know how x
got down to three?
AUDIENCE: Because x is the outer
procedure, and x and y
are the inner procedure.
PROFESSOR: Fine.
Well, I was very careful
and mechanical.
First of all, I should write
those procedures again for
you, pretty printed.
First order of business, because
you're probably not
reading them well.
So I have here that
procedure of--
was it x over there--
which is--
value of that procedure of y,
which adds x to y, lambda,
lambda, applied that to three,
takes the result of that, and
applied that to four.
Is that not what I wrote?
Now, you should immediately
see that here is an
application--
let me get a white
piece of chalk--
here is an application,
a combination.
That combination has this
as the operator
and this as the operand.
The three is going in
for the x here.
The result of this is a
procedure of one argument y,
which gets applied to four.
So you just weren't reading
the expression right.
The way you see that over here
is that here I have the actual
procedure object, x.
It's getting applied to three,
the list containing three.
What I'm left over with
is something which
gets applied to four.
Are there any other questions?
Time for our next small
break then.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's see, at this point, you
should be getting the feeling,
what's this nonsense
this Sussman
character is feeding me?
There's an awful lot of
strange nonsense here.
After all, he purported to
explain to me Lisp, and he
wrote me a Lisp program
on the blackboard.
The Lisp program was intended
to be interpreted for Lisp,
but you need a Lisp interpreter
in order to
understand that program.
How could that program have told
me anything there is to
be known about Lisp?
How is that not completely
vacuous?
It's a very strange thing.
Does it tell me anything
at all?
Well, you see, the whole thing
is sort of like these Escher's
hands that we see
on this slide.
Yes, eval and apply each sort
of draw each other and
construct the real thing,
which can sit
out and draw itself.
Escher was a very brilliant man,
he just didn't know the
names of these spirits.
Well, I'm going to do now, is
I'm going to try to convince
you that both this mean
something, and, as a aside,
I'm going to show you why you
don't need definitions.
Just turns out that that sort of
falls out, why definitions
are not essential in a
mathematical sense for doing
all the things we need
to do for computing.
Well, let's see here.
Consider the following small
program, what does it mean?
This is a program for computing
exponentials.
The exponential of x to
the nth power is if--
and is zero, then the
result is one.
Otherwise, I want the product
of x and the result of
exponentiating x to the
n minus one power.
I think I got it right.
Now this is a recursive
definition.
It's a definition of the
exponentiation procedure in
terms of itself.
And, as it has been mentioned
before, your high school
geometry teacher probably
gave you a hard time
about things like that.
Was that justified?
Why does this self referential
definition make any sense?
Well, first of all, I'm going to
convince you that your high
school geometry teacher was
I telling you nonsense.
Consider the following set
of definitions here.
x plus y equals three, and
x minus y equal one.
Well, gee, this tells you x in
terms of y, and this one tells
you y in terms of
x, presumably.
And yet this happens to have a
unique solution in x and y.
However, I could also write
two x plus two y is six.
These two equations have an
infinite number solutions.
And I could write you, for
example, x minus y equal 2,
and these two equations
have no solutions.
Well, I have here three sets
of simultaneous linear
equations, this set, this
set, and this set.
But they have different
numbers of solutions.
The number of solutions is not
in the form of the equations.
They all three sets have
the same form.
The number of solutions
is in the content.
I can't tell by looking at the
form of a definition whether
it makes sense, only by
its detailed content.
What are the coefficients,
for example, in the
case of linear equations?
So I shouldn't expect to be
able to tell looking at
something like this, from some
simple things like, oh yes,
EXPT is the solution of this
recursion equation.
Expt is the procedure which
if substituted in here,
gives me EXPT back.
I can't tell, looking at this
form, whether or not there's a
single, unique solution for
EXPT, an infinite number of
solutions, or no solutions.
It's got to be how it
counts and things
like that, the details.
And it's harder in programming
than linear algebra.
There aren't too many theorems
about it in programming.
Well, I want to rewrite these
equations a little
bit, these over here.
Because what we're
investigating is
equations like this.
But I want to play a little with
equations like this that
we understand, just so we
get some insight into
this kind of question.
We could rewrite our equations
here, say these two, the ones
that are interesting, as x
equals three minus y, and y
equals x minus one.
What do we call this
transformation?
This is a linear transformation,
t.
Then what we're getting here
is an equation x y
equals t of x y.
What am I looking for?
I'm looking for a fixed
point of t.
The solution is a fixed
So the methods we should have
for looking for solutions to
equations, if I can do it by
fixed points, might be
applicable.
If I have a means of finding a
solution to an equations by
fixed points--
just, might not work--
but it might be applicable to
investigating solutions of
equations like this.
But what I want you to feel is
that this is an equation.
It's an expression with several
instances of various
names which puts a constraint on
the name, saying what that
name could have as its value,
rather than some sort of
mechanical process of
substitution right now.
This is an equation which I'm
going to try to solve.
Well, let's play around
and solve it.
First of all, I want to write
down the function which
corresponds to t.
First I want to write down the
function which corresponds to
t whose fixed point is the
answer to this question.
Well, let's consider the
following procedure f.
I claim it computes
that function.
f is that procedure of one
argument g, which is that
procedure of two arguments
x and n.
Which have the property that if
n is zero, then the result
is one, otherwise, the result
is the product of x and g,
applied to x, and minus n1.
g, times, else, COND,
lambda, lambda--
Here f is a procedure, which
if I had a solution to that
equation, if I had a good
exponentiation procedure, and
I applied f to that procedure,
then the result would be a
good exponentiation procedure.
Because, what does it do?
Well, all it is is exposing g
were a good exponentiation
procedure, well then this would
produce, as its value, a
procedure to arguments x and n,
such that if n were 0, the
result would be one, which
is certainly true of
exponentiation.
Otherwise, it will be the result
of multiplying x by the
exponentiation procedure given
to me with x and n minus one
as arguments.
So if this computed the correct
exponentiation for n
minus one, then this would be
the correct exponentiation for
exponent n, so this would
have been the right
exponentiation procedure.
So what I really want to say
here is E-X-P-T is a fixed
point of f.
Now our problem is there might
be more than one fixed point.
There might be no
fixed points.
I have to go hunting for
the fixed points.
Got to solve this equation.
Well there are various ways
to hunt for fixed points.
Of course, the one we played
with at the beginning of this
term worked for cosine.
Go into radians mode on your
calculator and push cosine,
and just keep doing it, and you
get to some number which
is about 0.73 or 0.74.
I can't remember which.
By iterating a function, whose
fixed point I'm searching for,
it is sometimes the case that
that function will converge in
producing the fixed point.
I think we luck out in this
case, so let's look for it.
Let's look at this slide.
Consider the following sequence
of procedures.
e0 over here is the procedure
which does nothing at all.
It's the procedure which
produces an error for any
arguments you give it.
It's basically useless.
Well, however, I can make
an approximation.
Let's consider it the worst
possible approximation to
exponentiation, because
it does nothing.
Well, supposing I substituted e0
for g by calling f, as you
see over here on e0.
So you see over here,
have e0 there.
Then gee, what's e1?
e1 is a procedure which
exponentiate things to the 0th
power, with no trouble.
It gets the right answer,
anything to the zero is one,
and it makes an error
on anything else.
Well, now what if I take e1 and
I substitute if for g by
calling f on e1?
Oh gosh, I have here a procedure
of two arguments.
Now remember e1 was appropriate
for taking
exponentiations of 0, for
raising to the 0 exponent.
So here, is n is 0, the result
is one, so this guy is good
for that too.
However, I can use something for
raising to the 0th power
to multiply it by x to raise
something to the first power.
So e2 is good for both
power 0 and one.
And e3 is constructed from
e2 in the same way.
And e3, of course, by the same
argument is good for powers 0,
one, and two.
And so I will assert for you,
without proof, because the
proof is horribly difficult.
And that's the sort of thing
that people called
denotational semanticists do.
This great idea was invented
by Scott and Strachey.
They're very famous
mathematician types who
invented the interpretation
for these programs that we
have that I'm talking to
you about right now.
And they proved, by topology
that there is such a fixed
point in the cases
that we want.
But the assertion is E-X-P-T
is limit as n goes
to infinity of em.
and And that we've constructed
this by the following way.
--is Well, it's f of, f
of, f of, f of, f of--
f applied to anything at all.
It didn't matter what that was,
because, in fact, this
always produces an error.
Applied to this--
That's by infinite
nesting of f's.
So now my problem is to make
some infinite things.
We need some infinite things.
How am I going to nest up an f
an infinite number of times?
I'd better construct this.
Well, I don't know.
How would I make an infinite
loop at all?
Let's take a very simple
infinite loop, the simplest
infinite loop imaginable.
If I were to take that procedure
of one argument x
which applies x to x and apply
that to the procedure of one
argument x which applies
x to x, then this
is an infinite loop.
The reason why this is an
infinite loop is as follows.
The way I understand this is I
substitute the argument for
the formal parameter
in the body.
But if I do that, I take for
each of these x's, I
substitute one of these, making
a copy of the original
expression I just started
with, the
simplest infinite loop.
Now I want to tell you about a
particular operator which is
constructed by a perturbation
from this infinite loop.
I'll call it y.
This is called Curry's
Paradoxical Combinator of y
after a fellow by the name of
Curry, who was a logician of
the 1930s also.
And if I have a procedure of
one argument f, what's it
going to have in it?
It's going to have a kind of
infinite loop in it, which is
that procedure of one argument
x which applies f to x of x,
applied to that procedure of one
argument x, which applies
f to f of x.
Now what's this do?
Suppose we apply y to F. Well,
that's easy enough.
That's this capital
F over here.
Well, the easiest thing
to say there is, I
substitute F for here.
So that's going to give
me, basically--
because then I'm going to
substitute this for x in here.
Let me actually do it in steps,
so you can see it
completely.
I'm going to be very careful.
This is open, open, lambda of
x , capital F, x, x, applied
to itself, F of x of x.
Substituting this for this in
here, this is F applied to--
what is it--
substituting this in here, open,
open, lambda of x, F, of
x and x, applied to lambda of
x, F of x of x, F, lambda,
pair, F.
Oh, but what is this?
This thing over here that
I just computed, is
this thing over here.
But I just wrapped another
F around it.
So by applying y to F, I make
an infinite series of F's.
If I just let this run forever,
I'll just keep making
more and more F's outside.
I ran an infinite loop which
is useless, but it doesn't
matter that the inside
is useless.
So y of F is F applied to y of
F. So y is a magical thing
which, when applied to some
function, produces the object
which is the fixed point of that
function, if it exists,
and if this all works.
Because, indeed, if I take y of
F and put it into F, I get
y of F out.
Now I want you to think this
in terms of the eval-apply
interpreter for a bit.
I wrote down a whole bunch of
recursion equations out there.
They're simultaneous in
the same way these are
simultaneous equations.
Exponentiation was not a
simultaneous equation.
It was only one variable I was
looking for a meaning for.
But what Lisp is is the fixed
point of the process which
says, if I knew what Lisp was
and substituted it in for
eval, and apply, and so on, on
the right hand sides of all
those recursion equations, then
if it was a real good
Lisp, is a real one, then
the left hand side
would also be Lisp.
So I made sense of
that definition.
Now whether or not there's an
answer isn't so obvious.
I can't attack that.
Now these arguments that
I'm giving you
now are quite dangerous.
Let's look over here.
These are limit arguments.
We're talking about limits, and
it's really calculus, or
topology, or something like
that, a kind of analysis.
Now here's an argument
that you all believe.
And I want to make sure you
realize that I could be
bullshitting you.
What is this?
u is the sum of 1/2, 1/4, and
1/8, and so on, the sum of a
geometric series.
And, of course, I could
play a game here.
u minus one is 1/2, plus 1/4,
plus 1/8, and so on.
What I could do here--
oops.
There is a parentheses
error here.
But I can put here two times u
minus one is one plus 1/2,
plus 1/4, plus 1/8.
Can I fix that?
Yes, well.
But that gives me back two
times u minus one is u,
therefore, we conclude
that u is two.
And this actually is true.
There's no problem like that.
But supposing I did something
different.
Supposing I start up with
something which
manifestly has no sum.
v is one, plus two, plus four,
plus 8, plus dot, dot, dot.
Well, v minus one is surely two,
plus four, plus eight,
plus dot, dot, dot.
v minus one over two, gee,
that looks like v again.
From that I should be able
to conclude that--
that's also wrong, apparently.
v equals minus one.
That should be a minus one.
And that's certainly
a false conclusion.
So when you play with limits,
arguments that may work in one
case they may not work
in some other case.
You have to be very careful.
The arguments have to
be well formed.
And I don't know, in general,
what the story is about
arguments like this.
We can read a pile of topology
and find out.
But, surely, at least you
understand now, why it might
be some meaning to the things
we've been writing on the
blackboard.
And you understand what
that might mean.
So, I suppose, it's almost about
time for you to merit
being made a member of the
grand recursive order of
lambda calculus hackers.
This is the badge.
Because you now understand, for
example, what it says at
the very top, y F equals
F y F. Thank you.
Are there any questions?
Yes, Lev.
AUDIENCE: With this, it seems
that then there's no need to
define, as you imply,
to just remember a
value, to apply it later.
Defines were kind of
a side-effect it
seemed in the language.
[INTERPOSING]
are order dependent.
Does this eliminate the
side-effect from the
[INTERPOSING]
PROFESSOR: The answer is, this
is not the way these things
were implemented.
Define, indeed is implemented as
an operation that actually
modifies an environment
structure, changes the frame
that the define is
executed in.
And there are many reasons for
that, but a lot of this has to
do with making an interactive
system.
What this is saying is that if
you've made a system, and you
know you're not going to do any
debugging or anything like
that, and you know everything
there is all at once, and you
want to say, what is
the meaning of a
final set of equations?
This gives you a
meaning for it.
But in order to make an
interactive system, where you
can change the meaning of one
thing without changing
everything else, incrementally,
you can't do
that by implementing
it this way.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Another question
on your danger slide.
It seemed that the two examples
that you gave had to
do with convergence and
non-convergence?
And that may or may not have
something to do with function
theory in a way which would
lead you to think of it in
terms of linear systems, or
non-linear systems. How does
this convergence relate to being
able to see a priori
what properties of that
might be violated?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
The answer is, I don't know
under what circumstances.
I don't know how to translate
that into less than an
hour of talk more.
What are the conditions under
which, for which we know that
these things converge?
And v, all that was telling you
that arguments that are
based on convergence are flaky
if you don't know the
convergence beforehand.
You can make wrong arguments.
You can make deductions, as if
you know the answer, and not
be stopped somewhere by some
obvious contradiction.
AUDIENCE: So can we say then
that if F is a convergent
mathematical expression,
then the recursion
property can be--
PROFESSOR: Well, I think there's
a technical kind of F,
there is a technical description
of those F's that
have the property that when
you iteratively apply them
like this, you converge.
Things that are monotonic,
and continuous, and
I forgot what else.
There is a whole bunch of little
conditions like that
which have this property.
Now the real problem is deducing
from looking at the
F, its definition here, whether
not it has those
properties, and that's
very hard.
The properties are easy.
You can write them down.
You can look in a book
by Joe Stoy.
It's a great book--
Stoy.
It's called, The Scott-Strachey
Method of
Denotational Semantics, and it's
by Joe Stoy, MIT Press.
And he works out all this in
great detail, enough to
horrify you.
But it really is readable.
OK, well, thank you.
Time for the bigger
break, I suppose.